-It is so good to see you,
buddy. You look fantastic.
It is your --
-Thank you so much.
-It's your first time
here in person.
-Yeah. Yeah, no,
which is a huge relief.
'Cause last time we did this,
I was in my living room
and I got torrents of abuse from
the public for my cushions.
-Yeah, your couch cushions,
they didn't enjoy.
-They were not up to scratch.
Everyone was shocked that I was
not actually British royalty.
And it's like, "No, this is what
poor L.A. actors look like.
We're dirty. We're broke.
That couch has ramen on it."
That's how that works.
-That's the way it works, yeah.
-Pretty much.
-I know you were
just at Comic-Con.
This is your first time
at Comic-Con.
-Yep. Yep, nerd Mecca.
It was amazing.
-Yeah.
-It was absolutely incredible.
-It really is.
But you were in Hall H.
-Yes. Which is --
-For the first time anyone
has been there in three years
at Comic-Con.
-Yeah, it was the first Hall H
in three years.
Everyone was super hyped,
and we were going to Hall H
with "Dungeons & Dragons,"
which is pretty much
the heart of all things
Comic-Con and nerd.
-Congratulations.
Yes, congra-- By the way.
So, you played that trailer.
By the way, it has
over like 16 million hits,
so congratulations on that.
-Thank you very much.
-But the "Dungeons & Dragons"
trailer, you premiere it.
Hall H. And what do you see?
And what do they do?
-You don't see a damn thing
because you black out.
This thing's terrifying.
-It's terrifying.
-Like, I tried to ask, like,
Chris Evans and Ana de Armas
because they've
done this before.
I was like, "Hey.
I'm going to Hall H.
You got any survival tips?
And they're like, "Oh, my God!
Hall H?!"
-"Ohh!"
-"No, man, that's --" And
I was like, "Yeah, thank you.
Survival tips." They're like,
"Man, that's a lot.
You're gonna get overwhelmed!"
I got nothing from these people.
I got nothing.
-They told you nothing.
And so they play it,
and then everyone loved it.
That's got to feel --
That's got to feel good.
-It felt great.
It was the hugest relief.
'Cause like, the unofficial
tagline of "Dungeons & Dragons"
is, "Dungeons & Dragons:
No, no, wait, hear me out."
-No, it is really good, yeah.
-And, like, this is it.
We walked in, and it's like
bringing this movie to meet
mom and dad, because
this is the judge and jury
of "Dungeons & Dragons."
And they all went,
"oh, my God, it doesn't suck!"
And we're like, "Yes!"
-Yeah. Exactly.
Congratulations.
-Thank you!
-That's lot of pressure.
-It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But it's not your first turn
in a fantasy movie.
Of course -- Yeah.
Let me jog your memory.
Of course, we all remember you
from "Harry Potter."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you were -- There's
a thing online, they said,
"Oh, my gosh, Rege-Jean Page
is a background actor
in 'Harry Potter.'"
Is it seven maybe?
-Maybe.
-Yeah, maybe.
-You're telling...
-Well, you know what? Let's just
show a clip, 'cause we have one.
Here we go.
♪♪
-They are coming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the scene.
♪♪
Did you enjoy doing that?
-Yeah, no, hugely.
I mean, the best thing
about, like, background acting,
particularly on big movies
like that --
and I recommend it
to every actor out there --
is, essentially, no one
pays attention to you
in the background,
so you get to be best actor spy.
I was just watching, like,
how these directors work
with these actors,
where Emma Watson hides
her phones between takes.
Like, it was just --
And this is the valuable stuff.
It was under the tablecloths
at the wedding, by the way.
-That's where they do it. Wow.
-Sorry, Emma.
-Yeah. Can we talk about
"The Gray Man"?
-Yeah, all day long.
-This is an action movie,
and it is action-packed.
It is fantastic.
It's a lot of action.
-Yeah, it's huge.
-Yeah, and this is
the Russo brothers,
who are known for their
huge Marvel films.
-I mean, just a couple
little indie films.
-Yeah. The biggest movies
in the world.
-The highest-grossing movies
pretty much of all time.
-Yeah. How did you connect
with those guys?
How did they hook up with you?
-I mean, there's different
versions of this story.
So, like, there's a version that
Joe tells where his wife watched
"Bridgerton," there's a
version where he watched
it with his wife.
There's a version where Anthony
says he was, like, at --
picking up his kids, and all
the mums were talking about me.
And he was like, "I need
to know who this dude is."
-Yeah.
-I mean, the common thread is,
essentially, some powerful men
had the women in their lives
talk to them, and we all know
who run the world at this point.
-Yeah, yeah, we know
who runs the world.
Exactly. That's correct.
-I think we do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
So you get to work with these
guys, and you go -- This is --
I mean, the whole film
is a giant, giant fun film.
Ryan Gosling.
You got Chris Evans.
-Mm-hmm.
Incredible and hilarious.
-He is a great guy.
He's just a fun --
-Gosling's got the most
wonderful, wry, absurdist humor.
And I think that Evans is very
kind of begrudgingly grateful.
Because I think the --
the "trash 'stache" thing,
that's a Gosling original.
He was just, like, throwing out
disses to Evans between takes.
It was just like,
"It looks like a trash 'stache."
Like, "You hit like a..."
Like, it was just, like,
Gosling lines.
-Back and forth, yeah.
It started with Gosling.
-There's a ton of those
on the cutting-room floor.
-Who do you -- Can you tell
everyone who you play?
-I play a man called
Denny Carmichael.
He is the deliciously
devious head of the CIA.
Here's the CliffsNotes.
Essentially,
I'm Ryan and Chris' boss,
I tell them to go out across
the world and punch each other
in the face, and they do.
-There you go.
That's a great way
to sum up the film.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rege-Jean Page
in "The Gray Man."
Take a look at this.
-Six.
-Want to explain
whatever that was?
-Gun jammed.
-That doesn't qualify
as an explanation.
-Maybe on a secure line.
-I need a status report.
Insecure line.
Did the target say
anything to you?
-Well, he was dead,
so, you know, no.
-What about pocket litter?
Did you get anything
off his body?
Six, did he have anything
on his person that you now have
that you'd like to give to me?
-Who was he?
-A bad guy.
-Yeah!
He's a bad guy. Watch out.
Rege-Jean Page!
"The Gray Man" is streaming
right now on Netflix.